in 2017 Russia reduced the punishment
for domestic abuse beat a family member
for the first time and if they don't end
up in hospital it's not a crime efforts
to reintroduce a law against domestic
violence were picking up pace towards
the end of last year but now because of
kovat they've been put on hold which
means that if you're beaten at home
during lockdown the law won't do much to
protect you and if you're the one doing
the beating you know that it won't come
after you
Irina loonette's kaya was a victim of
domestic violence herself and now she's
helping others evade quarantine to come
here
very few shelters are open because of
the lockdown but she's managed to get a
system up and running there's no code
word system in Russia to call for help
the fact there's no system during
lockdown at all just the old saying you
hear again and again if he beats you he
loves you this woman says her husband
attacked her when he was drunk the first
time he'd been physically violent
[Music]
started receiving the Devonian didn't he
what difference will it make to you if
there was a law against domestic
violence and go
even just a protection order might have
saved margarita glass over her hands
which were cut off by her husband two
years ago after she asked him for a
divorce
why am sanjaya Bradshaw has some nieces
who just go home on leash when he still
wants it more with you company has a
closure against Whitaker yet she has
tried to use her profile to raise
awareness even during quarantine to get
people to wash their hands her story
turned into a play last year to raise
the alarm over domestic violence but
activists faced strong opposition from
conservative Orthodox forces who argue
that what happens behind closed doors is
a family affair
parvo is a member of the ruling party
United Russia still have a lot of
children without having any violence in
the family domestic violence has risen
the world over during the pandemic but
Russia says it's gone down last month
NGOs wrote to the government asking for
emergency measures to help victims of
domestic violence they've still had no
answer Diana Magnay Sky News Moscow